المعركة التي ليس لها مثيل الا
الحرب العالمية الثانية. معركة
تحديد المصير معركة حياة او موت
بالنسبة للأوكراني. وهي معركة عدم
الخسارة والخروج بوجه مشرف
لروسيا في هذه الحرب. الالاف
قتلوا في هذه المدينة. الجثث
متناثرة في الارجاء. المباني
مدمرة. عشرات المقابر الجماعية.
الجنود المدينة التي اتجهت وتتجه
اليها انظار العالم. لماذا كل
هذا الاصرار من موسكو للسيطرة
على المدينة? ولماذا يستميت
الاوكران في الدفاع عنها? وما
الذي يميز هذه المدينة عن غيرها?
وكيف يختبئ الالاف من الناس داخل
مصنع واحد? ما الذي تعنيه سيطرة
روسيا على المدينة استراتيجيا
وعسكريا? وما الذي تعنيه خسارة
المدينة بالنسبة للاوكران. لماذا
ماري بول؟ سؤال يراود الجميع
دائما خلال هذه الحرب. لماذا صب
الروس جم قواتهم لاخذ المدينة؟
ولماذا كل هذا الصمود من قوات
اوكرانيا على مدى شهرين كاملين؟
ماري بول ثاني اهم مدن منطقة
دونسك باقليم دومباص كان يعيش
فيها اكثر من نصف مليون نسمة قبل
الحرب لكن عددهم قد يصل الى مائة
الف نسمة فقط. تبعد ماريبول عن
حدود روسيا بنحو خمسة وخمسين
كيلو مترا. سيطرة موسكو عليها
تعني خلق بري يربط اراضيها بشبه
جزيرة القرم. تعد ماريبول نافذة
اوكرانيا الابرز على بحر ازوف.
وخسارتها تعني تحول البحر الى
بحيرة روسية لا سيما بعد سيطرة
روسيا على ميناء الاوكراني في
منطقة ميناء ماريبول اكبر موانئ
بحر ازوف وكان معبرا رئيسا
للصادرات الاوكرانية الى دول
العالم. خسارة ماريبول تعني
خسارة اربعين بالمائة من صناعة
التعدين في اوكرانيا لصالح روسيا
بحسب وزارة الاقتصاد الاوكرانية.
فهي مصدر رئيس لاستخراج وتصدير
الحديد والفولاذ وفيها مصنع
ازوفستال احد اكبر مصانع التعدين
في اوروبا والعالم. واما عسكريا
فهي ضربة للقيادة العسكرية
الاوكرانية وفق خبراء عسكريين
فان سيطرة موسكو على ماريبول
توجه ضربة قوية لاوكرانيا ويزيد
من التهديدات لها. مدينة ماريبول
كانت مركزا رئيسيا لقيادة القوات
الاوكرانية في عملياتها ضد
القوات الانفصالية بمنطقة دونسك
منذ عام الفين واربعة عشر.
وسقوطها يعني خسارة ابرز المواقع
في المنطقة سيطرة روسيا على
ماريبول تعني فتح جبهة ثالثة
قوية ضد المقاومة الاوكرانية في
منطقة دونيسك. بينما يرى البعض
ان روسيا بحاجة عاجلة الى تحقيق
نصر ما يسد ثغرة الخسائر الكبيرة
في قواتها والعجز عن التقدم على
عدة جبهات. وستكون السيطرة على
المدينة تمهيدا لاحتفال موسع في
عيد النصر التاسع من مايو
المقبل. حال المعركة. ستون يوما
هي الفرق بين هذه الصور قبل
المعركة وهذه الصور الاخرى
بعدها. فانظروا ماذا فعلت الحرب
بهذه المدينة. عشرات الالاف من
الجنود الروس يحاصرون المدينة
لشهرين كاملين. وقوات كييف
تستميت في الدفاع عنها مع انقطاع
للامدادات ونقص في الذخيرة
والعتاد. قيادي في قوة مشاة
الاوكرانية التي تدافع عن اخر
معقل للقوات الاوكرانية في مدينة
ماريبول المحاصرة. ربما نواجه
ايامنا ان لم يكن ساعاتنا
الاخيرة. العدو يفوقنا عددا
بمعدل عشرة الى واحد. نناشد
ونلتمس من جميع زعماء العالم
مساعدتنا ونطلب منهم استخدام
اجراء اخراج القوات ونقلنا الى
منطقة تابعة لطرف ثالث. هذا هو
حال جنود اوكرانيا المحاصرين في
ماريبول. القوات الروسية ليست
وحدها في هذه المعركة. فهناك
قوات شيشانية مدربة بقيادة
الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان قديروف
تجربة قوات قديروف شكلت مكسبا
حقيقيا لجيش بوتين ليثبت قديروف
في ماريبول انه ليس الفتى
المدللة لبوتين فقط بل ويده
الحديدية الضاربة. الحصين. وبعد
ان سيطرت روسيا على معظم اجزاء
المدينة اعطت لقوات كييب مهلة
بعد اخرى للاستسلام لكن الجنود
الاوكران مع ما تبقى من المدنيين
وهم بالالاف تحصنوا في مصنع يدعى
ازوفستال ليتحول المصنع الى اخر
معاقل المقاومة الاوكرانية في
وجه الاجتياح الروسي. وتقدر
الاحصائيات الروسية ان المصنع
يحوي الاف المقاتلين الاوكران
كما الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي ان الف
مواطن عالقون فيه منذ اسابيع وسط
القصف الروسي المتواصل ومحاولة
موسكو اجبارهم على الاستسلام.
ورفضت القوات الاوكرانية
المحاصرة في المصنع شروط الروس
بالاستسلام متعهدة انها ستظل حتى
اخر قطرة دم. بينما تعد السيطرة
على مصنع ازوفستال مهمة صعبة
للقوات الروسية. فهو على مساحة
احد عشر كيلومتر مربع ويحوي
متاهة من الانفاق والممرات بطول
اربعة وعشرين كيلو مترا تحت
الارض والتي سمحت للمدافعين عنها
بالمناورة البحرية لصد الهجمات
الروسية. وقبل الحرب استعدت
السلطات الاوكرانية للهجوم
الروسي من خلال تأسيس مخزونات من
الطعام والماء في ازوفستال. لكن
ذلك لن يكون كافيا بالطبع للالاف
داخل ذاك المصنع. المصنع يغطي
مساحة شاسعة ويمكن للاوكرانيين
التحرك عبر الانفاق وتغيير
مواقعهم. في الجانب المقابل حال
بقيت ماري بول صامدة فلا يمكن
للروس اعادة نشر ما بين عشر الى
اثنتي عشرة من وحدات النخبة في
مناطق اخرى شرق اوكرانيا.
وبالتالي فان المدينة تواصل
تشتيت انتباه قوات الجيش الروسي
واحباط خطط الكرملين هجوم في
دومباص. نتائج المعركة. تقول
التقارير ان الاف المدنيين لقوا
حتفهم في المدينة فضلا عن القتلى
من الجنود مع تضاؤل فرص الحصول
على الطعام والماء وانقطاع
الكهرباء ومقابر جماعية تضم
المئات من القبور والكثير من
الجثث اما تحت الانقاض واما
مرمية في الشوارع تهدمت المباني
وخراب في البنية التحتية انها
نتائج الحرب يا سادة. عمدة
ماريبول فادين بوي شينكو يقول ان
واحدا وعشرين الف شخص على الاقل
قتلوا في المدينة حيث افترشت
الجثث الشوارع وقال ان القوات
الروسية استخدمت محارق جثث
متنقلة للتخلص من اي ادلة على
ارتكاب مجازر ومنع المنظمات
الدولية من توثيق الرعب الذي يعد
الجيش الروسي مسؤولا وبعد هذا
كله لجأ الاوكرانيون الى مصنع
ازوفستال. وهناك تم حصارهم.
بوتين يعطي اوامر باجتياح
المصنع. يخرج حينها الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي ويحذر ان تم ابادة
القوات المتبقية في ماري بول.
فستنتهي اي فرصة لمفاوضات
السلام. ولن يبقى غير الحل
العسكري عندها. بعد ذلك وجه
بوتين كلمة الى وزير دفاعه. ارى
ان اقتحام المنطقة امر غير
ضروري. واطلب منك الغاء ذلك.
بوتين اشار الى ان قراره كان
بدافع الرغبة في حماية ارواح
الجنود الروس وقال ليست هناك
حاجة للدخول الى هذه السراديب
والزحف تحت الارض عبر هذه
المنشآت الصناعية. لكنه امر
الجيش الروسي وقال اغلقوا هذه
المنطقة الصناعية حتى لا يمكن
لذبابة ان تمر من خلال جاء كل
هذا بعد ان اعلن وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجي شويغو السيطرة على
مدينة ماريوبول وحصار ما تبقى من
قوات كييف داخل مصنع ازوفيستال.
قرار منتظر لقوات اوكرانيا
المتبقية في ماريوبول. فهل
يستطيعون البقاء لفترة اطول
لاستنزاف الروس اكثر? او حتى
تفتح ثغرة جديدة لوصول الامداد
واستمرار المعركة في المدينة. في
كل الاحوال ستبقى المدينة اهم
الركائز للطرفين خلال الحرب في
اوكرانيا.